[Music]
a clip I smile gamer at their happiness
there it exceeded our estimates and
today rimbaud is a game that
every day we win players euros
in earnings for the year 2 it is a year
in which  In any case, we have planned to
push
the meta of the game even further and the
operators who arrive in the future are
much more representative
of Sydney's vision of what we want to do
and don't worry about the old
operators  they will also always go to the
operator table where they will be redone
in some parts and it is therefore we
will always maintain all of our
operators
what we know is that we have worked a
lot on the first anti chip
years of research also on the claude
network side and so on for year 2 in fact
we will continue to make efforts in
any case to improve comfort we will
see a first milestone where we will
completely modify loose business an
overhaul of matchmaking at two levels
it's already v  to be a one-
step matchmaking we take a pool of 10 players from eqii
its assembly we redistribute all at
once and pass the two teams are
done and then more than that an overhaul
also in which the matchmaking is done
on a bubble  on the side which means
that you are free to act whenever you
want you want in the menus we
can manipulate the game completely
while the matchmaking is done
so comfort and quality match
[ __ ] whatever we are going  do in the future
on the coming months on the coming seasons
and more will be able to go
directly into these interfaces there this
menu there it is planned to receive
all the Greek zones of the future we will
also send loot for the players
and I  want to give access to
almost all the bank says m
that we have today in the game but
in addition we will thank the players for
their time I play you and we
give you easter wolves you can
open for free we more  you j  hear
more you have twins fides
distinguish us all for swimming pool in pro
league challenge league
raf program introducing meggiorini
bosphorus playstation and xbox wii is
five formats of the hadopi jury if you
believe in work radiant platform
reporting turn to concoct a program
of six where  we don't leave building in
quiberon a competitive and
inspector date to do a second year
that means it works that is to say
it works it means that the game has
in fact proven everything it should
do and today  Today we were
born beyond our expectations so we are we
are very happy and this year two
it's extraordinary this time we
are sending a message a
tracleer to everyone what we
are fighting for I am  beats anyway c was born
here to stay
I
[Music]